uh anyone who's got my book it will say
don't go backwards to go forwards but
some people don't understand that
if i go here
get it out
and do it then it's okay but i've
actually used that with strength
there's another one that nick was
showing if i if i do go up
and take it then it's basic because i've
got one hand on it but what am i going
to do now
it just cut it just come from that
height
it went to that height now it's back at
this height where's it going to go again
you know
look i know you're a prize fighter and
you're in the street and you had too
many drinks but can you give me a half
an hour because i need this technique
you ain't you haven't got i've been in
real situations and you don't it's
milliseconds you've got milliseconds
that's that technique you was doing
i can't lift it up lower it down i can't
do anything more so where does it come
from
let's do it simon so you can see see
this hand
see now we've got two techniques that
look exactly the same
i don't know what foot he's got forward
so
i could be like this
but
it would help if i'm in hand me but i
could be like this
because i don't know what foot he's got
forward i have to choose what way i'm
going to go
so i'm going to
go this way or this way
this way this way how am i going to lift
my arms up
i can't lift him up so i'll leave him
where they are
i take it out i leave him where he is
i step out here we're back to almost now
dory if you think about it and then i
push him down
so i've now got two techniques that i
don't have to worry about oh how many
techniques we've got to remember
because i'm starting to piece them
together slowly
if i
do this
and that
from usher though
i can't bring it
i can't bring it up
but i can leave it there and i can move
my buttock to my hand my buttock to my
hand
okay and there you know the rest
okay
on a gas mask